I am well-appointed how with anxiety
there's a guy called David linson who
for me to find anxiety better than
anyone I've ever come across and he said
anxiety is basically temporal
dislocation
but this means essentially is that some
early trauma some formative fear some
disquiet that happened at a vulnerable
age has become stuck in your system it
is undigested trauma and so that past
experience is now brought to the
doorstep of every moment
you meet every moments not with
curiosity but with a prism of
expectations fears and resignations you
leapfrog from what's happening directly
to the conclusions and the conclusions
are negatively parsed anxiety is a
proneness to negative emotion so back to
David linson anxiety is temporal
dislocation the past experience makes
you over determine the present over
determinate right misjudge it over
determine what's happening and conjure
up immediately in mind fill the contents
of mind with dread that conjure up a
future that becomes identified with the
end of days at least for you everything
goes catastrophic todo is catastrophic
or in lament a de Lancie oh so I know
this feeling well the media
insidiously feeds back into this loop of
misappropriating the present right over
determining and conjuring up a future
identified with doom because the media
right follows the basic protocol that if
it bleeds it leads more coverage is
given to disaster - explosion - disease
- death - chaos - catastrophe then -
everything else which warps then our
perception about the state of things
through constant exposure to the doom
and gloom broadcasts saturating the
body-mind and seeding the contents of
consciousness so that eventually our
mentation our experience of ourselves
and of the world again is parsed
negatively you watch the news for too
long you come to think you are actually
in danger of a terrorist attacked so
much more often than you would ever be
the chances of actually dying in a
terrorist attack are something like less
likely than you falling and dying in the
shower but it saturates our brains right
you board an airplane or a train or
you're in a public venue I certainly
feel this I'm like oh my god I hope
somebody doesn't blow themselves up in
this place
when the statistics say otherwise
[Music]
so here we are the past fear of trauma
the past programming over determining
the present conjure up a fusion that
becomes identified with doomed temporal
dislocation no longer properly assessing
what's happening and instead the whole
world caves in you cloud your cognition
clouds and now you're like in a
viscerally anxious state hypochondriasis
is no different something I can also
relate to right I just went swimming in
a beautiful River free-floating foaming
water in a UNESCO heritage site I am on
in heaven on earth and yeah you know
what I brought to the doorstep of that
moment I was like oh my god do I have
any open wounds oh my god is there the
flesh-eating bacteria in the water
because I read this story on CNN about
this this woman and she had like an open
cut on her leg and she went swimming in
the lake and then some bacteria got in
there and two days later they had to
amputate her because she had some
necrosis facilities flesh-eating
bacteria that eat her legs and I
literally I literally was scared to go
swimming in this beautiful flowing river
because of that article and yet how many
people per year how many millions of
people for a year go swimming in rivers
I said what is the percentage of those
people that actually get some
flesh-eating bacteria but again the past
trauma the miss reading is brought to
the doorstep of every moment anxiety
clouds our judgment our compulsion to
make ourselves feel safe constraints our
freedom in the moment robbing us of all
the joy of living and turning us into
neurotic incessantly looping and erotic
case studies in fibrillating anxiousness
what gaming wheel calls the 21st century
normals
well bummer
human default condition perpetually
future-focused negatively parsing said
Oh is afraid numbing the angst with
xanax the United States of xanax how do
we free ourselves from such a burden how
do we actually practically proactively
keep ourselves safe because you don't
want to be reckless but find ways of
mitigating against the uselessness
constriction and violation of our bliss
by our goddamn anxiousness
[Music]
I am so tired of my fear I am so
tired of being afraid I'm so
tired of the rigidity that Rob's
me of my desire to dance and
sing what the fireflies it is
said that one way to cure trauma is with
an equally powerful experience tinged
with positivity rather than PTSD they
call it inverse PTSD Roland Griffiths
from Johns Hopkins University coined the
term to describe what happens when
people have healthy containers for
mystical experiences in which they are
able to move beyond their lenses of
perception have an encounter with an
experience of knowledge by acquaintance
that everything is fine that you will be
all right and that those lenses of
perception tinged with fear are no
longer serving you you can dispense with
them there is another place to plant our
feet and therein lies the Holy Land the
healing of our fractures
the dance with the beyond the Bliss
crucifixion the death and resurrection
the art the lie that reveals the truth
the fiction that is more truthful in
reality the timeless placed beyond death
and beyond fear the cosmological giggle
at the end of time staring at the iris
of your lover's eye when you went to God
just to see and you were looking at me
and it was all set to a pop song and how
awesome is that happy ending
that happily ever after that
consummation that consecration that
communion with the feeling felt in
pregnancy that everything is gonna be
okay so don't worry about a thing cause
every little thing is gonna be alright
rise up this morning smile at the Rising
Sun three little birds beside my
doorstep singin sweet songs of melodies
pure and true this is my message to you
so you don't worry about a thing because
every little thing is gonna be alright
[Music]
don't worry about a thing
every little thing is gonna be alright
[Music]
I promise